die besser wenn man es mal eine rüstung
machen dass man hier von den vielen
leuten ja leute das ist energie nein
nein du bist alt
so was geht ab heute ssk hier aus dem
speicher stall und mit mir ist der mo
yan minecraft richtig so und wir zocken
heute ändern games auf gala.de wichtig
dass sein
specials spielmodus der ganz ganz viele
ändert es beinhaltet die erste es geht
um eine mega geleckt okay ich bin
einfach nichts bekommen nichts auf einem
dach gelandet auf dem ruf ja ich habe
jetzt fünf dinge ihr wundert euch
wahrscheinlich warum ich jetzt gerade
fünf also barenboim aus einer kiste
geholt habe das liegt daran ist diese
ändert es ziemlich gut bestückt sind
genau wie ich und ja kamera direkt mal
fünf alles rausholen oder was mir auch
schon passiert ist vier diaz ich hab ich
übrigens nicht gewundert
wir machen jetzt mal schnell ein irons
wenn die 60 sekunden schutzzeit
auslaufen die es vor jedem jahr vor
ihrem spiel gibt dann wird aufgeklappt
und aber natürlich gut bewaffnet seien
aber zumeist von haus aus gut bestückt
wann ist noch was anderes da muss man
aber trotzdem gut bewaffnet sein
durch die sind ja gar kein scherz gerade
ja ich bin auch keine rolle
ist doch überhaupt gar nichts mehr
keiner ernsthaft gar nichts die
schutzdämme gleich und ich habe auch ich
hab mich mal ein schwert stützt ist zu
ende und ich sehe keine gegner kommt
dran kommt alle ran
hitler reimt sich auf schwimmen nicht
wirklich von ibrahim land die trendwende
schon beinahe tisch sein willst nicht so
rassistisch was was so wie vieles habe
ich jetzt viel eisen okay da drüben ist
einer den snack muss ja hallo kollege
hätte was sagt dann eben hier und ascona
das noch getötet
ich habe ein getötet ja und dann will
ich queckborn der heute so ist ender
games immer richtige action und die sind
heute ja kommentierte man die
abwehrkräfte
es ist halt wirklich wirklich schwierig
ich mache ich frag mich ob ich jetzt die
20 sekunden nehmen soll diese schwer zu
kräften
weil man in der zeit gerne mal gesagt
wenn du erster bist dann hast du gute
chance sofort nachdem sofort was das
alles zu machen sondern sein sagt einer
der ist daun
die menschen werden sich gar nicht ein
bisschen es nicht meine schuld leute
kommen nicht so viele 24 ist ja noch
einer
wer ist da und ja läuft bei mir ne falls
euch die kids bisher gefallen haben
lasst mal einen daumen hoch da ein like
neumann
ach so ich dachte ich sag nur bisher ich
möchte kleine zwischenbilanz und 65 an
den spielmodus hieraus händler games auf
dem hd geile sache schütteren dich komm
es nicht kommen ich weiß aber ich sag's
seine akkus trophy eine anekdote ja und
jetzt schon wieder eingekehrt man
richtig dicke stefan stern sturz durch
eine falle von new york
nein ich war absichtlich keine gefahr
gebaut
die hs tor entfällt also ernsthaft nicht
suchende traut niemals trat niemals
mojang minecraft wenn er irgendwas
überfallen sagt bei einer game 2 man
kann sich das portmonee es gibt so
gibt's natürlich vor spezies die ist
dann so kleine fallen bauen und methoden
ich habe einen bogen
da gibt es später die sich zufallen
bauen sich zum beispiel den solarer
aufbauen
wenn dann der nächste dahin gebaut wird
fällt er in dieses loch reißt ganze
anzahl das werden sicher bald alle
machen dann also ist es ist nun mal so
wenn einer das macht gut ankommt weil
ihr wahrscheinlich an machen am anfang
ist ein punkt sammeln doch kreativ drei
tage zwei tage wo also fresh ist es
frisches update jedoch schon richtig
geil was ich biete beste action das
neueste vom neuesten heute noch 64 das
gehört ja ja sechs spieler und ich finde
niemanden von der wehrmacht im 18
da ist die welt zu ende okay das heißt
der kontrahent angreifen
wie wär's denn wo ist unser unter
profitable egal 19 besser wenn man es
mal eine rüstung machen
dass man hier von den vielen leuten ja
leute das ist an der games für sie
versucht euch gerade eine einrichtung zu
kräften
und ja wenn ihre alten dem moment
weggepustet so redet dann ist nicht nur
des iron wächst oder komplettes album
sondern auch die gute alte workbench so
den geben uns mal sagt er
geburtstag richtiger bogens killer auch
und auch wenn die gegner unter wasser
gehen macht jemand auch kaputt
properties die welt zieht wieder funken
ok läuft so halbwegs gar nicht schlecht
noch vier
ich würde sagen nichtangriffspakt geht
noch wer ganz lustig wenn wir mal ins
finale kämen dann sich dass das hier
gewinnen würde
nur 39 uhr 1 bis 3 jahren damit kann ich
mir aber nichts machen ich bin immer
alles im falle gebaut
nein aber ich habe es einfach nicht
lassen er ich lasse wasserstadt
lagerplatz ihr ja nicht ob lara und dann
darüber was platziert weil ich mich wenn
ich mich selber angebrannt hab ja ich
habe auch hier war die man gerne sind
auch drei dass die flex klassen wie cave
getauscht die wahrscheinlichkeit liege
bei 50 prozent dass ich das gleich ein
gebiss gewesen glaube ich hätte mir die
seele aus dem leib geschrien
totti war nicht so doch ich hab mir ja
was ich hab mich so liebt
ach ja liebe leute jetzt wo ich keine
behinderte weihnachtsmelodien schreibt
mal in die kommentare wie eure
weihnachtsfeiertage was habt ihr gemacht
das interessiert mich schreibt mir was
ihr an geschenken bekommen hat falls ihr
das nicht hinter meinem video getan hab
letztens schreibt mir jetzt in die
kommentare
damit ich mal gucken kann was meine
abonnenten so alles bekommen habe
erzählte was ich zu bekommen habe nein
nein nein du bist hatte gesagt keinen
fall
da müssten sie fliegen spieler der
aktion zwei minuten läuft
es tut mir wirklich nicht leicht so
etwas ja meister am fuß das kennenlernen
hat das mach ich noch wenigstens fertig
ich bitte dich mich verliere jetzt
einfach da ist der kollege ich wie groß
navis nicht die große natürlich nie
deswegen hast du natürlich weiß was
machst du junge ich bin geistig
verhindert scheiße das kraftwerk liegt
mich gerade richtig für mich hat es ja
mal übels in die luft und das spectator
kollege hin
der pakt ist ja keine luft um einfach
gehabt hab ja komplett ohne bugs sind
größte hindernis und das war ganz normal
okay leute partner macht es gut wenn ihr
bock habt noch mehr von einer games zu
sehen schreibt auch in die kommentare
lasst uns wissen über ein like und einen
kombi und dann würde ich sagen macht's
gut haut rein und service